foreign
years ago as you may recall the world
faced an apocalyptic thread it was a
moment of existential crisis for all of
civilization we found ourselves on the
verge of planetary destruction and was
all because of plastic straws to this
day the images of stromageddon are still
stamped indelibly on our minds we saw
pictures of sea turtles with plastic
straws shoved up their noses you know a
situation that we decided to blame on
the straw and not on the sea turtle for
being clumsy frankly there were beluga
whales with straws jammed into their
eyes great whites with straws coming out
of their gills an entire family of
bottlenose dolphins were killed by one
single straw it was a catastrophe the
media insisted all of a sudden that we
had to ban plastic straws we had to get
rid of them they told us about the giant
garbage patch in the Pacific which was
evidently comprised almost entirely of
plastic straws from Starbucks McDonald's
they gave us a lot of other shocking
information but none so shocking as this
apparently countless media reports
insisted Americans use and discard 500
million plastic straws a day it's about
182 billion straws in a year which means
that every single American goes through
well over 500 straws annually every
American uses and throws away at least
one straw every single day without fail
we were told that means that if we were
to take all the straws we use in a day
collectively and lay them out one by one
on the ground they would wrap around the
world twice if we were to take all the
straws we used collectively in a year
and stack them end to end we we would
reach the moon 90 times
by the way I haven't done these
calculations myself I found them on a
random WordPress blog and I'm just
assuming that they're correct which as
it happens is exactly what the media did
with all of this strength anti-straw
information
specifically the media was repeating
data first Gathering reported by a
nine-year-old boy the child had come up
with the 500 million straws a day figure
by randomly calling a few straw
manufacturers on the phone and taking
whatever information they gave him and
running some mathematical calculations
that nobody ever checked and
extrapolating that Americans somehow
used half a billion plastic straws in a
single 24-hour period
this kid was
an authority figure on the subject of
plastic straws for whatever reason and
we were supposed to listen to him and
make adjustments according to what he
said CNN even brought him on for an
interview uh several years ago and
here's what that looked like let's talk
about so what inspired you to get folks
to be straw free
well um sometimes I think we forget that
every straw we use every piece of
plastic will be here on Earth somewhere
on Earth even when my grandchildren are
born long after that
okay now needless to say I have nothing
against this kid as a parent in fact I
can appreciate that he's focusing his
energies on this they're certainly less
productive ways that a child that age
could spend his time but the question is
whether any adult any major corporation
any government should actually take
marching orders from a third grader and
it wasn't just this one third grader
there was another nine-year-old child
standing at the Forefront of the
anti-plastic straw struggle here's
nine-year-old Molly steer in 2017
founder of the straw no more campaign
giving a TED talk to a group of adults
hi my name is Molly Stan and I'm nine
years old and I have just found out that
straws really do suck earlier this year
my mum and I went to see a movie called
a plastic ocean the movie said that all
over the world oceans are filling up
with our plastic rubbish this plastic
gets into our oceans and it hurts the
marine animals on my way home from
watching the movie that night I started
thinking about what I could do to help I
started thinking about plastic straws
now look on the bright side here even if
you feel that you've hit rock bottom in
your life even if you know it seems like
things couldn't possibly get worse at
least you've never attended a
nine-year-old's Ted talk now I don't
blame Molly for not understanding this
point she's a child after all but
um the the plastic in the ocean is not
really our rubbish quote unquote
actually 95 of the plastic in the ocean
comes from third world countries in
Africa and Asia outside those countries
Brazil accounts for the most uh so
Western countries account for a
comparatively minuscule amount of the
plastic pollution in fact there are many
countries with a fraction of the U.S
population that nevertheless produced
exponentially more pollution in the
ocean
and of the five percent of the problem
that all of Europe North America and
South America and Australia contribute
to and even tinier fraction is from
plastic straws so so tiny that you could
ban all plastic straws in all Western
countries and it would have basically no
effect on the pollution problem at all
not while places like Sri Lanka are
still dumping all of their garbage
directly into their Rivers which then go
out into the ocean if you're hiring you
know it's incredibly hard to attract top
talent and with the current labor market
conditions it's even harder than ever
that's why you want to partner like a
zip recruiter who gets it ZipRecruiter
knows how tough it is right now but they
figured out solutions for the problems
you're facing try them for free at
ziprecruiter.com Walsh to reach more of
the right people zip recruiter posts
your job to 100 plus job sites zip
recruiters smart technology finds great
matches for your job and then lets you
invite the most qualified people to
apply for your job their pricing is
really straightforward you can stick to
your budget with no surprises team up
with a hiring partner like ZipRecruiter
who understands what you need four to
five employers who post on simple
recruiter get a quality candidate within
the first day just go to this exclusive
web address to try ZipRecruiter for free
ziprecruiter.com Walsh again that's
ziprecruiter.com
ZipRecruiter the smartest way to hire
now children don't understand these
sorts of things or have this kind of
perspective which is which is
understandable
and it's why when a child says we should
get rid of all the plastic straws and
save the Earth
the appropriate response is to Pat them
on the head and say sure little guy that
sounds great and then proceed to ignore
whatever they said
that's not how our leaders responded
instead over the course of a few months
at the behest of a group of confused
elementary school children states and
cities around the nation banned plastic
straws many restaurant chains uh joined
the party and pledge to get rid of all
their plastic straws and move instead to
paper straws
this switch was made all over the
country and now today paper straws have
mostly supplanted the plastic variety
now paper
makes for a terrible straw on the merits
they dissolve in liquid which is the
opposite of what you want your straw to
do but at least we were told it's
healthier and more eco-friendly
even if plastic straws aren't really a
huge problem what's the harm in making
the switch if it'll make you know the
planet a better you know cleaner place
uh even if in a very minuscule way well
as it turns out uh the harm that it does
might be considerable The Daily Mail
reports today quote we may all think
we're doing our bit for the planet by
sipping our drinks out of a paper straw
but the eco-friendly Alternatives
contain long lasting and potentially
toxic chemicals a new study has
concluded in the first analysis of its
kind in Europe Belgian researchers
tested 39 brands of straws for the group
of synthetic chemicals known as poly and
perfluoral act
follicle whatever PFI pfas is what it is
pfas were found in the majority of the
straws tested and were most common in
those made from paper and bamboo the
synthetic chemicals are used to make
everyday products from Outdoor Clothing
to non-stick pans resistant to water
heat and stains they are however
potentially harmful to people wildlife
and the environment the substances break
down very slowly over time and can
persist over thousands of years in the
environment a prop a property that has
led to them being known as forever
chemicals they've been linked to a
number of health problems including
lower response to vaccines lower birth
weight thyroid disease increased
cholesterol levels liver damage kidney
cancer and testicular cancer
well there you go you might die of
kidney cancer but at least no sea
turtles will have straws jammed up their
noses
instead they'll just get cancer too it
gets even better reading quote analysis
revealed the majority of the brands 69
contained pfas with different pfas
detected in total paper straws were most
likely to contain the synthetic
chemicals the most commonly found pfas
has been banned globally since 2020 also
detected were another thing I can't
pronounce TFA we'll call it and tfms
Ultra short chain pfas which are highly
water soluble and some might Leach out
of straws into drinks the pfas
concentrations were low and since most
people tend to only use straws
occasionally pose a limited risk to
human health however pfas can remain in
the body for many years and
concentrations can build up over time so
that's the good news sure the paper
straws have lethal chemicals in them
that are actually dissolving into your
iced coffee as you drink it but as long
as you only use the straws occasionally
then the risk will be limited until it
builds up in your body over time and
kills you of course if we really go
through 180 billion straws a year
then we're in trouble
you know because what we were told to
begin with is that we don't use straws
occasionally we use them every day
so that's what we're left with the only
way that the paper straws won't do
severe damage to our health is if the
logic for using paper straws in the
first place turns out to be false
but then if that's the case
there's no reason to use them at all
now look at the Silver Lining though as
Molly said in her Ted Talk the plastic
straws plastic straws they use they can
harm you if marine animals eat those
straws and then you eat the marine
animals then you know indirectly you're
ingesting the plastic
well now we've cut out the middleman so
that we can just be harmed directly by
the straw instead so you can ingest the
straw by throwing it in the ocean
waiting for a fish to eat it then eating
the fish that's one way or you can just
ingest the straw by having it dissolve
into your beverage and drink it
which is what we're doing now
a brilliant strategy what this means is
that the people who banned plastic
straws never checked the data to confirm
that plastic straws were actually a
problem and never did any studies to
make sure that the alternative straws
would be better for people and the
environment
that's because the plastic straw Panic
never had anything to do with data or
facts and it was driven by by nor was it
driven by any sincere desire to protect
our oceans it was all just another giant
virtue signaling exercise another Petty
power grab by the collection of meddling
little tyrants who look for every
conceivable way no matter how small to
control our behavior when I say meddling
little tyrants to be clear I'm not
talking about the nine-year-old kids I'm
talking about the people who use those
nine-year-old kids as a pretense to
control yet another a seemingly small
aspect of your life
and that's really why you're using paper
straws
something to remember when you're
diagnosed with thyroid disease because
of it and that is why paper straws are
today canceled if you'd like to see what
else I have to say you can access my
full show by going to dailywire.com or
by going to the Matt wall Show Twitter
page hope to see you there Godspeed